اذا نفوذون بحجم دوله وصلاحيات تمتد على
طولها وعرضها يجعلني عوده ايران للاتفاق
النووي بالغه التعقيد في امبراطوريه
ضخمتها العقوبات لن يقبل اصحابها عوده
التعاملات القانونيه حتى انه لا يخفي
مصلحته في فرض المزيد من القيود ويحضرني
الان تصريح ابرز قاده الحرس محمد رضا نقدي
العام الماضي رحب بالمزيد من العقوبات قال
انها تشجع على الاكتفاء الذاتي صحيح
الحرس البائع الوحيد لنفط ايران في السوق
السوداء هناك 123 ناقله نفط تهرب النفط
الى الصين وحدها بحسب الايميل كما ان
الحرس الثوري يبقى مستفيدا من حاله العداء
الايرانيه مع واشنطن لجهه اجنداته
التوسعيه الميليساويه في المنطقه وبالطبع
لا يريد فتح ابواب الاستثمارات برفع
العقوبات عن بلدنا ان يحارب فيها الحارس
الثوري على القطاع الخاص المحليه رغم ذلك
تطرح ايران العوده المفاجاه للاتفاق اذا
عدتم عدنا هكذا خاطب عبد الله قوى الاتفاق
وبشروط اسهل من قبل لو قبل المسؤولون
الغربيون فاينقذون النظام الايراني
اقتصاديا ويخرجونه من ازمه الداخليه لكن
الرد الغربي جاء بترتيب الاولويات
الاحتجاجات حقوق الانسان ووقت بيع مسيرات
الايرانيه لروسيا والرد الامريكي
[موسيقى]
فيديو توم وجيري